India has lost one of its most
celebrated actors Irfan Khan died on
Wednesday in Mumbai after a two-year
battle with cancer
he was just 53 now leading the tributes
we had Indian Prime Minister Narendra
Modi calling Khan's death quote a loss
to the world of cinema and theatre
Khan's award-winning career spanned
three decades and more than 80 films he
was one of the first Bollywood stars to
crossover to an international market
with roles and critically acclaimed
films such as Life of Pi and Slumdog
Millionaire as well as blockbusters like
Jurassic world and for more let's bring
in actor Adil Hussain who is has worked
with Irfan Khan he's joining us now from
Delhi welcome to the program and thank
you so much for joining us on this
somber day what was your reaction when
you heard about Khan's passing my first
reaction was first unbelievable I could
not I do I knew that he was unwell and
we were not we haven't met many times
except for life of five premieres and
but that he joined film industry much
before me and his portrayal of roles
were the windows for me to see his
vulnerability and his the beauty that he
possessed and they empathy that he
bought in me as a person and gave access
to the characters that he played I never
knew that I will feel so sad when I
heard my I felt a punch in my heart and
I am still whelmed and we mentioned that
you worked with him on the 2012 film
Life of Pi that went on to garner 11
Oscar nominations how is it working with
him it is he was a phenomenal actor
and I always looked up to him after I
saw his first my friend first film of
which I saw was namesake and that's the
time I fell in love with him before that
I knew him as an actor but I also wasn't
in the film industry till 2010 myself I
was very involved in theater but when I
saw his film namesake directed by Mira
nya I realized that the craft that he
learned to be able to express himself
with a most vulnerability and which
where he sort of embodied the character
in a wholesome way to give access to the
audience to look at his soul so as a
person I interacted with him few times
and I always felt that he is in a deeper
quest through his rules about his own
life so we ended up speaking few things
but I realized that his search for
himself through the craft that he
practiced perhaps one of the qualities
which really you know set him apart what
was he like beyond the film set he was
always smiling
he had his wits and his sense of humor
was absolutely excellent I remember his
smiles very well and his warmth he was
very down to earth he never believed
much in trills and glamour and all bad
because he's objective of being an actor
was the was was to capture the reality
and with you cannot capture the reality
of a character the kind of characters
that he played was from you know from
very very real life and not from the nor
the characters from the high-flying
people with Oakland though he stayed
don't do according to my observation and
tell us just briefly before we go I mean
because we see from the reactions on
social media that really India and the
world we have to say is united in
overwhelming morning overwhelming praise
for him what do you think his legacy
will be oh my god he will be remembered
as one of the finest actors in India for
sure and his contribution to world
cinema as well
he always didn't like the term volume
because he believed that the the Indian
film industry is very different than
Hollywood film industry so he will
remain as one of the most revered actors
most respected actors and also that
inspiration from new kind of actors in
India to portrayed roles with lot of
realism which generally wasn't the case
in so-called Bollywood film industry so
he is looked at as an actor who has
changed the trend of Indian acting than
the the realism of Indian acting so he
will be remembered with lot of fondness
love reverence and respect I do Husain
we thank you so much for joining us to
share those those warm tributes to your
your friend your colleague Irfan Khan
dead at the age of 53 we appreciate it